The joe rogan experience.
Does the exercise work
better or the same as work?
Like for managing depression?
Uh, the workout is maintenance.
It doesn't achieve much, but I achieved
the workout. But do you feel like the,
the endorphin release, does that
help you yet? Yeah, it does. And I,
as the Buddhist say I made merit.
I went in there and did my time on the
treadmill. I don't want to be there,
you know, like this, like
the last 15 minutes. I don't,
I'd rather be somewhere else like, Yo,
it's cool. You'll be fine. Sit Down,
do your work.
That's why before the podcast how
suggesting hot yoga to you and you,
you seem to be very stiff lately. You've
got some injuries and some things back.
Yeah. Dude, I'm telling you that'll fix
a lot of that shit. It'll really, yeah,
I know you, you have, you have
a great workout diversity. You,
when you and I were talking before we
were at your place and you said some
mornings you feel like training this
way and you'll go to that gym or you'll
train plug would judo or whatever.
And then the next day it's
going to be kettle bells,
so you really like to mix it up.
I think it's good for a body to always
be guessing what's coming next. Yeah,
I think that's important. I also, I,
there's some things that
are really have to do.
I think I need at least one day of hard
cardio a week and I think I need at
least one day of hard
lifting weights a week,
but I also think I need at least one
day of yoga. We can at least yogas.
To me it's one of the most important
things that I do because for that 90
minutes I can't go anywhere. I don't
touch, my phone's on in the room with me.
It was just me and a a jug of water and
the Yoga Mat and the class and a bunch
of old ladies that are kicking my ass.
These old ladies are fucking tough man.
This is old lady.
She goes to this workout class.
May I see you there all the time.
She's got to be close to 70 she doesn't
even bring water. She just Tufts it out.
She's there for 90 minutes,
sweating and grunting through the postures
and those lie you do in an hour and a
half class,
those last 20 minutes in a 104 degrees,
it's so hard to get through,
but when you get through you
just feel like you feel better.
I just almost like can't while I'm in it,
I can't wait to do it again.
Like while I'm struggling and I was
like, God, I need to do more than this.
I need to do this more often rather
I can't wait to do this again.
I always feel that and it
just lengthens everything.
Like all the back things
and the leg things,
the hamstring things just
stretches everything out
and lengthens it and all the
tension.
It just straightens it out and loosens
it up and I just feel like for a guy like
you or I who does a lot of a lot of like,
especially like you still
a lot of heavy lifting,
you were saying a lot of
dead lifts and squats.
This is the antidote for all that
stuff, right? It's deep compression and,
and for your body maintenance,
it's just phenomenal.
Probably let's loose the lactic acid
out of your muscle tissue. Yeah, yeah.
You know, here's what I've observed.
You know, I live in Los Angeles,
so there's a lot of yoga people,
but you know,
I know them because they have a mat.
But you could also see how they walk,
how they sit. There's
so in their body. Yeah.
And there is a grace to,
you know,
I'm not trying to put
anyone in the pejorative,
but a yoga person where there's
not only are the limber,
they're just really okay though
this their body articulation,
you're like, okay, I don't have that.
I'm a Herky Jerky, uncoordinated person.
But there is a,
uh,
uh hum coming from that
person's overall body. It just,
it's a beautiful machine.
The way they articulate
themselves and the way these sit.
And why unusual balance. The balance of
like you can tell someone who does it,
they have that and it's not subtle. I
recognize that you would love it, man.
You know what?
You would love it cause it fucking sucks.
And while you're doing it, man, you
have the internal dialogues, crazy.
You want to bolt where you want a ball,
but you also start going over your life
and your mind and dealing with all your
bullshit and your to do list and
all the things you're, you're,
you're doing it wrong or slacking.
There's something about really struggling
in these static positions for like a
minute where you're trying to like
hold your leg up there and your sweat.
Sweat is literally pouring
off your arms and your head.
And there's something about that man
that it's just really cleansing it just
really empty.
I just think it's a thing that you're
missing that you would really love if you
try it.
I bet if you did it and they came back
and we did a podcast year later and be
like, fuck you. Oh God, I fucking
love it. It's changed my life.
It's changed my life.
I know a lot of fighters,
a lot of people who like are hectic
for living. Yup. They're yoga people.
And like in the 70s you say yoga, so it
was going to punch you like yoga. Wham.
Well, you know what I found out about
it. How do you know Hixon Gracie is,
are we talking about the Gracie
family? Well, the family hoists,
Gracie is the most famous because he's
probably the most important figure ever
in the history of martial arts because
he won the first ultimate fighting
championship and showed that a small
man could actually beat larger men with
technique and skill.
Well his brother is Hickson
and his brother is like
universally regarded as one
of the greatest Jujitsu guys if
not the greatest of all time.
And he was different than everybody
else and that he did yoga.
Like his thing was like, I'd never heard
of a martial artist that got into yoga,
but Hixon would do these breathing
exercises and they do these balance beam
exercises and he was always doing yoga
and stretching and that was a giant part
of his workout and he was above and
beyond everyone else in his time period.
Like in the 90s everyone was scared
of Hixon. He was the man. I mean,
but it wasn't like there was any debate.
It's very rare that you get something
that is so a antagonistic and so tightly
contested as two men using
martial arts techniques,
trying to strangle each other and one
guy stands above all by such a large
margin and that was Hickson.
And I really do believe that
part of it was his mind.
Part of it was his physicality,
but a lot of that physicality was enhanced
by his dedication to Yoga, Huh? Yeah.
He's a legit Yogi.
Like he does that fire breathing shit
where he sucks his stomach in in that
weird way and has it move up
and down. Wow. You ever see
somebody to do that? Yeah,
he does that like a, like
a real yogi look. It's,
it's a real trip and I
think because of his,
uh, his, his, his like physical like
you could see you there. He's good.
He's got this video here. You could
see him do this fire-breathing Shit.
Like watch what he does this stomach
cause it's kind of fucking crazy.
He sucks his stomach way, way,
way up deep into his rib cage.
He does this breath of fire
thing and then as it gets going,
he starts pumping is look here, you
see if you pull it up there, Jamie,
the part where he starts to do it,
they'll look at this. Wow. Yeah.
Like what the fuck? Isn't
that insane? Yeah. It's crazy.
And this is one of the things.
He has a dominant all muscle control.
Droopy. You never try and articulate,
make it do anything. Yeah. Well He,
you know, he'd practice yoga
for a long, long, long time.
And because of that he had this phenomenal
core strength and phenomenal balance
and he just had a giant
advantage over everyone else.
And I think a lot of
that advantage was his,
his ability to move his body
was different, but it also,
just for a guy like you that's been
just lifting weights for so long,
it's the perfect antidote for your body.
It's like your body will react to like,
oh yeah, stretch this out.
Thank you. Thank you. Have
been asking for this. Yeah,
but Linkedin, this, hold that pose. This
is instead of just lifted something raw,
you know,
which is like what men like to do.
Instead of that you're holding your arms
out, they're like, dad, you're like, fuck,
I don't even have any weight
in these things and I want
to drop them. Yeah. I've,
I did a,
you know,
every once in a while I've worked out
with someone else and they go, okay,
we're going to do this and this and that.
You work with and then you let them,
you let yourself be trained. Yeah. And
I've done a few workouts like, okay,
I'm going to kill you. I'm like,
okay, well what does that mean?
Like by the end of this,
you won't be able to take your
shirt off to change and I've done,
you know where you're benching
this much then this much,
then this what you need to do like 150
reps and by the time you can't lift the
bar and you can't lift your arms, you're
literally trembling from exhaustion.
And I've told that to
people. They go, that's yoga.
You will tremble from exhaustion.
Yeah.
And you'll be so happy when you leave
because of how good you feel and you can't
wait to go back and you won't
blow your joints out. Yeah.
The way you will with
weightlifting. I already have. Yeah.
There's no way around it.
I've paid.
Okay.